welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for invincible season two it's
gonna be dropping the first four
episodes on November 3rd and it's been
well over two years since we last Saw
Mark Grayson working through his daddy
issues with Omni man so we are gonna
break down this trailer frame by frame
to see if we can figure out what's in
store for season two of this incredible
animated series and don't forget to
subscribe to our newest channel the
break room where you can always find
more awesome discussions and Analysis of
all things fandom also sag after has
informed us that entertainment
journalism Outlets like new rockstars
are allowed to analyze movies and TV
shows this video not a paid promotion we
support the actors and the writers on
their strike let's get started with the
breakdown
for some of you it probably seemed like
this day would never come
maybe you're even wondering if you're
ready for this
[Music]
for what comes next
you have no idea what I'm capable of
okay we open on a graduation stage with
the voice of Reginald Vel Johnson as
principal V in Winslow saying for some
of you it probably seemed like this day
would never come the setting is Reginald
Vel Johnson High School and it's a
graduation for the class of 2023.
probably a double entender in reference
to high school students yearning to just
leave high school and fans of invincible
season one that ended in April of 2021
who never thought season 2 would come
while the character of being Winslow as
principal Reginald veljohnson high
school was established in the comic
books they actually got original Val
Johnson to voice a character on the show
it's one of my favorite things about
this and the name being Winslow
obviously a reference to the Winslow
Family on the show Family Matters of
which Reginald played the dad who's
always trying to make Steve Urkel the
kid who his character in Die Hard said I
shot a kid right it wasn't just a
wholesome TGI Friday show he was trying
to murder Steve anyway Mark's girlfriend
Amber voiced by zaisy beats looks over
at the empty chair next to her Mark has
been flying through the city as
invincible and is missing his own
graduation it looks like Adam Eve voiced
by Gillian Jacobs is sitting next door
we get a shot of invincible seemingly
after defeating a bunch of magma Knights
these creatures have been known to work
with Doc seismic who we'll see later in
this trailer Invincible then gives us a
menacing line reading of you have no
idea what I'm capable of okay on to the
next clip
I didn't know who he was
his name he's
Invincible flashing across the screen
here and we see what might be Mark
standing in City Rebel in front of a
giant screen that shows the still
picture of invincible Sandra O's name
flashes on screen as her character
Debbie Grayson Mark's mom says I didn't
know who he was tears streaming down her
face as she looks upward toward the sky
we next get a look at the villains
magmaniac and tether Tyrant as they rob
a bank Meg Maniac can control lava and
yeah it is lava not magma because when
it's above the Earth's surface it's lava
and tether Tyrant can control these 30
tendrils that Spawn from his chest both
of these henchmen are associated with
the villain Machine Head who we met in
episode 5 of the first season of
invincible and then we're introduced to
another villain doc seismic as they
gleefully destroy a tall Standalone
building with their Quake Powers the
advanced gauntlets on the wrist gives
them the destructive quality in fact you
can actually see them clanking together
as they fall wanna max out Max get
Disney plus plus see all of peacock's
feathers make Netflix okay I don't
really have a good one for Netflix but
if you want to make sure you're getting
full access to your streamer's Content
Library you need need expressvpn we use
expressvpn all the time in New rockstars
here's an example we want to watch a
specific scene from The Fellowship of
the Ring which we can't because it
doesn't show up here but with one click
expressvpn tells Netflix we are in Italy
and Netflix tells my brain I'm in Middle
Earth it's one VPN to rule them all if
you run out of stuff to watch in Italy
expressvpn lets you set your location to
any one of the over 90 countries that
way you can just pop over to a new one
to find your new favorite show no
passport required expressvpn works on
your phone laptop even smart TVs so you
can watch your shows from the comfort of
your couch or on the go and it's super
fast so there's zero buffering no wonder
expressvpn has been called the best VPN
of 2023 expressvpn is a must-have make
sure you go to expressvpn.com new
rockstars you'll get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free on the
next clip I don't fight France because I
would win never apologize for saving
lives there's only one way this kid goes
back out there and that's on a very
short leash I'm just happy helping
people
[Applause]
do you know people trying to kill us
every single day right I don't care how
old he is he needs to go down now
maybe if you train more and complained
less we could get back to saving lives
next we get a montage of the names and
voices of some of the Incredible
characters we met in season one of
invincible including Seth rogans Alan
the alien who says I don't fight friends
because I would win and we actually saw
him in the season 2 teaser trailer that
they put out back in January if you
remember Invincible battles The Immortal
in the sky at night he's voiced by the
incredibly talented actor Ross Marquan
who's also known for his ability to
imitate voices he of course played The
Red Skull in Avengers Infinity war and
in-game and what if he's also provided
the voice of Ultron and what if and the
centuries and Multiverse of Madness
Invincible he's also the voice of
Rudolph Rudy Connors robots clone we
hear Amber say never apologize for
saving lives and Walton Goggins as
Steadman head of the global Defense
Agency tells us that he thinks Mark
should be kept on a very short leash we
see Invincible fighting doc seismic at
the top of a pyramid and then we get the
shot of invincible flying toward a red
portal in the middle of a city that
appears to be a gateway to a much larger
City somewhere else does it look like an
alien or futuristic city but it could be
a look into this IP's own take on the
Multiverse more on that in a minute who
else is going to look at Adam Eve
getting ready to unleash her powers an
invincible beaten up on his old friends
the Mahler Twins and after a flex of all
the incredible voice Talent they've
already had on the show we see what's
coming next for season two onto the next
clip make him pay for what he did to
your world welcome sign up here who
slayed my husband I am a normal human
superhero I wish he was dead too but not
for your sake kill fast and ask
questions later
oh yeah
feltramide against viltromite that has
not happened since the Great Purge
you should have died at Birth okay we're
shown a mega list of the voice talent
that will be new to this season we know
who a few of these folks will be playing
but most don't have their characters
listed on IMDb we at least can make some
guesses and tell you where you've seen
or heard everyone before let's do it
Chloe Bennett played quick in ages of
Shield the hilarious Rob Delaney was the
iconic Peter from Deadpool 2 and just
showed up in Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one Luke McFarlane who is
awesome in Bros Jay Pharoah from SNL
raise seahorn from Better Call Saul who
finally got her much to serve Emmy
nomination this year Carrie Walgren a
voiceover actor with a metric ton of
credits including Rick and Morty and
Star Trek lower decks this is probably
her saying welcome son of he who slayed
my husband she could be playing the
comics character Anissa who was teased
at the end of season one Chantal van
Stanton from the boys Cliff Curtis from
Avatar the way of water Calista
flockhard from Ally McBeal and Supergirl
wife to Harrison Ford scoot McNary the
winner of 2023's most fun name to say
award is actually listed on IMDb playing
King Lizard okay character from the
comics it actually kind of sounds like
him saying kill first and ask questions
later the lizard league is cobra-like
evil cabal was already teased back in
season one freaking Leah Thompson from
freaking Back to the Future Camden Coley
a young actor who's appeared in Abbott
Elementary Peter Cullen the voice behind
Optimus Prime and the Predator he plays
the character we see later in the
trailer who says viltromite against
viltromite that has not happened since
the Great Purge not sure if this voice
is a Comics character or not but he
might be part of some filter might
counsel the Great Purge doesn't appear
to be a big event in the comics Canon
but the Villager mites do seem to be
working toward a goal of purging weaker
species so this is probably something
they've done in the past maybe one group
of ultramites purged another one who
they thought would be weaker or inferior
either way it looks like the show will
give us an expanded or different history
than we got in the comics Tim Robinson
from I think you should leave and
corncob TV Fame will no doubt be doing
some hilarious shouting on this show
Eric Bowser an amazing voice of Her
actor who does the voices for most of
the Looney Tunes in their recent
cartoons Sterling K Brown from Black
Panther who played killmonger's dad it
sounds like him saying make him pay for
what he did to your world Reports say
that he'll be playing the comics
character angstrom Levy a mad scientist
who opens up the Multiverse Kirkman has
said that the Multiverse will play a
role in the second season Tatiana
maslani the legendary She-Hulk attorney
at law defeat Diggs from Hamilton that's
probably him saying I wish she was dead
too but not for your sake I don't have
any good guesses for who dicks might be
playing from the comics so if you have
any let us know in the comments Ella
Purnell from Yellowjackets Lincoln Boden
another young actor who has been on
9-1-1 Lone Star Josh Keaton the voice of
Peter Parker in The Spectacular
Spider-Man Paul F Tompkins a legendary
stand-up comic whose voice you've
probably heard a bunch of stuff like
BoJack Horseman and Jellystone Ben
Schwartz who provides the voice for
Sonic the Hedgehog it sounds like his
voice saying I am the normal human
superhero my guess is that he'll be
playing the comics character shapesmith
who is teased back in season one Micah
Ali Ling another kid actor with only a
couple of short films listed on their
IMDb Cleveland Berto from the Terminator
movie and finally Phil Lamar from
Futurama Pulp Fiction in the Mad TV a
bunch of stuff even with all of this
great voice Talent at Comic Con Robert
Kirkman revealed that two actors who
turned down roles for the show were
comedian Connor O'Malley and Brian
Cranston but he didn't reveal who either
of them were supposed to play and so our
trailer ends with a confirmation that JK
Simmons is returning the zombie man
complete with an incredibly devastating
line that one can only assume he's
delivering to his son Mark hey I want to
thank our team of writers including
Brandon Barrett Gina eboluto Jordan
Morrison Erica wusu for writing and
researching this breakdown please
subscribe to all three of our channels
so you can support me on allsocials at
EA boss and you can support us by
grabbing some merch at nerdright.shop
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time bye
[Music]